[Music]
on this sunday night
a province in crisis and the help on its
way
thousands of new cases in ontario every
day
now health care workers from across
canada are headed to the epicenter
of the country's pandemic canada's
financial picture
will the federal budget tackle child
care and extend pandemic measures
remembering the 22 people killed in one
of the country's
worst massacres the unthinkable happened
here and
peloton warning the danger to children
with this
popular fitness product
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the dire
situation in ontario the province is
consistently reporting more than 4 000
new cases of covet 19
every day and there are a record 2 100
people in hospital
now several provinces and territories
are stepping up to help the doctors and
nurses
on the front lines our ottawa
correspondent michaela couture has been
combing through the details
mike robin we were given details of this
plan at a press conference
late sunday afternoon the federal
government will be sending
health care workers and equipment to
help ontario
as it continues to battle
record-breaking coveted 19
case numbers that help comes mainly in
the form of
nurses who work now at national defense
and immigration canada they will be
deployed
to the greater toronto area in
particular now some of them
will help with rapid testing while
others will go right to the front lines
in hospitals our government has offered
to cover
all of the costs and coordinate the
movement
of health care staff from other
provinces
to the front lines in ontario including
using military aircraft to help deliver
this help to ontario with covet 19
burning like a wildfire across parts of
ontario the federal government
has al also asked other provinces and
territories if they can spare
health care workers to come help prime
minister justin trudeau says that he
spoke to the premiers
of the atlantic provinces as well as the
territories seeing if they have any
extra resources now in a statement a
spokesperson
for ontario's health minister christine
elliott told global news
they're grateful for the federal
government's help adding
quote we will continue to work with all
levels of government and healthcare
partners to protect the health and
safety of ontarians
and combat this deadly virus now
all of the costs as minister leblanc
just said will be covered
by the federal government this
particular pandemic spending
won't be accounted for though tomorrow
in the federal budget but if you were
looking
for hints about what we might see in
that budget
federal finance minister christopher
freeland dropped one last
dropped a hint last week at the liberal
policy convention
maybe an epiphany as you put it on the
importance of early learning and child
care hi erin
it's widely expected the liberals will
be laying the groundwork for a national
child care program freeland and
economists have spoken about the
importance of child care
in starting the she covery of our
economy
the impact of the pandemic has
disproportionately affected women
it's just like a road or a bridge if you
were to cut off 30
of the roads and bridges in your
provinces you think you can reopen and
everything's fine
no you're going to have to do something
about that part of the infrastructure
child care is critical social
infrastructure the government has said
stimulus spending over the next three
years will be between 70
and 100 billion dollars as canada
emerges from the pandemic the
parliamentary budget officer pegs last
year's deficit
at 363 billion dollars and next year's
is estimated to be about one-third of
that at 121 billion
economists say once you get beyond the
sticker shock
you need to see if that spending is
putting canada's financial future in a
better position
as long as you can make uh those those
good investments those targeted
investments that would boost canada's
economic capacity and that's the tough
part so that's what the government will
have to carefully consider
as it prioritizes its spending plans
part of that could mean pivoting towards
a
low carbon economy and other sectors of
innovation
are we going to focus on innovation that
includes green but also
software artificial intelligence biotech
resilience those aspects
so will this budget lead to an election
election while a new ipsos poll done
exclusively
for global news says 53 percent of
canadians
don't feel it's necessary to go to the
polls this year
and those people may get their wish the
ndp has already said
it will not trigger an election during
the pandemic
robin mike licoteur in ottawa thanks
mike
back to the situation in ontario there
is a fierce debate over how the province
should get a handle on the pandemic
on friday the ford government gave
police more powers to stop
people breaking stay-at-home orders but
health care advocates say the provincial
government
is missing the point catherine ward
reports
words from ontario's solicitor general
sent communities into a tailspin friday
police will have the authority to
require
any individual who is not in a place of
residence
to first provide their purpose for not
being at home
and provide their home address causing
widespread condemnation from civil
rights advocates who call the rules
unconstitutional to police forces who
publicly said they would not follow the
government's orders the directive was
modified late saturday and now reads
if a police officer or other provincial
offenses officer
has reason to suspect that you are
participating in an organized public
event or social gathering
they may require you to provide
information to ensure you are complying
with restrictions
a spokesperson told global news these
measures are meant to discourage
gatherings and crowds that violate the
province's stay-at-home order
aimed at curbing the spread of covet 19.
and while the second version is more
nuanced in its wording
advocates still question its intent to
me that language is not different enough
and if anything the harm has already
been done many critics say they are
worried placing a focus on the role of
police could make matters worse
i'm not convinced that this change in
wording will necessarily make people
who are racialized people who who live
in low-income areas feel any safer
especially when there's tends to be more
enforcement in these communities already
and might even have the opposite effect
in helping fight coveted 19.
having police presence is just going to
drive people
particularly marginalized and racialized
people into their homes
into more unsafe situations it's going
to
worsen the trust that already exists and
make it less
likely that people will want to go out
of their homes to get vaccinated
while the province maintains paid sick
leave is a federal matter
and it will not duplicate an existing
program the calls from experts are
consistent when it comes to how to
protect
the most vulnerable we need to do better
we need paid sick days
we need paid time off for vaccination
and we need to a total
shift in how we're approaching coven 19
in ontario a call science experts say
they hope
the government will take seriously
catherine ward
global news toronto the pandemic is
derailing the federal government's
ambitious plan to boost immigration over
the next three years
there's already a backlog of
applications that need to be processed
and for those who thought they were
approved they're still waiting to get in
as mike delay reports it's put the
program in limbo
it was last fall when canada issued a
confirmation of permanent residency
or copr to the mishras they saw it as
the final piece to their immigration
puzzle
they sold their house and car lined up
good paying i.t
jobs in toronto and pulled
seven-year-old rishana out of school
she keeps on drawing a lot of pictures
the way she imagines canada
but just as they were about to leave
india they were told by immigration
canada to stay
put that copr only becomes a
confirmation
upon arriving in canada so they're now
living in an airbnb
with no resolution in sight we are
getting sleepless nights it's like um
the mental trauma that we had been going
through because
we are in a limbo the canadian federal
government has pointed to immigration as
essential for the country to recover
economically from the pandemic but the
university of waterloo's michael
scooterux says that's a misleading
argument
suggesting canadian immigration is
mostly about the needs
of an evolving workforce and the best
evidence is
that when you increase immigration
levels in the middle of a recession you
don't get good outcomes
because they're scarce jobs i mean very
clearly crowds workers out of jobs that
are
people that are already here um that are
jobless we
we have record levels of joblessness
right now the pandemic certainly put the
brakes on immigration due to tougher
border restrictions
the number of new canadians dipped by
almost 50 percent from 2019 to 2020.
just this week the federal government
announced a program to expedite 90 000
applications from essential workers
as part of its goal to bring in 1.2
million new immigrants
over the next three years we are
definitely expecting a surge
and now i don't know how how powerful
and when that story is going to happen
but there is a monumental
epic pent-up demand for immigration
services of every kind
and that he says will trigger a log jam
of cases that could take months or even
years to clear
because immigration canada can only
process so many cases in a day
they could hire more staff or relax the
standards to enter the country
but experts say both those options are
unlikely
and that means families like the mishras
will just have to wait
indefinitely mike durley global news
toronto
nova scotia is remembering the lives
lost in one of the worst mass murders in
canada
one year ago the close-knit town of
porter pick was terrorized
when a killer posing as an rcmp officer
went on a killing spree
in that 13-hour rampage 22 people died
today their families and friends
gathered to grieve ross lord reports on
a tragedy
that remains surreal a year later
after a year of feeling angry and
bewildered
devastated nova scotia communities are
using this dreaded anniversary to
remember the victims
while moving forward almost a thousand
people
running or walking in person and
virtually to honor the lives lost
it's surreal it's like it it felt
surreal when it happened and it's still
every time i come through this way it's
always
it's always hard julian irani is running
her 12th marathon
she's wearing 22 hearts on her back
they're all the people we lost
so it's just for them there are
widespread gestures of
support the woman receiving this hug is
jenny kierstead
she helped organize memorial events
while grieving the loss of her sister
lisa mccully constable heidi stevenson
[Music]
many families are marking the occasion
in private including
tyler and kelly blair tyler wants to
believe he's doing a bit better than one
year ago
when his parents greg and jamie blair
were killed i say
better it's not much better
no because it's always there yeah
yeah it's always so i don't know maybe
i'm not doing better
the same goes for kelly greg blair's
sister she's angry
families have not been given more
information about what led to the mass
shootings
and how the gunman was able to carry on
with his rampage for 13 hours
tyler and kelly say they've received
tremendous moral support
and tyler says his two younger brothers
who were forced to hide out for hours
with lisa mccully's two young children
are receiving therapy it definitely
helps because they do
different source of counseling they do
like horses and stuff
so that helps smiles don't come easily
except for when the blares remember how
greg and jamie
live their lives in the moment
usually the life of the party especially
my old man
he was a he's a wild one
the mass killings touched everyone in
nova scotia where there are few degrees
of separation
at a time when the pandemic makes it
hard to assemble collectively
these efforts are a point of pride in
the environment of covet that we're able
to do this is very empowering you know
no matter what it took to have to do it
to line up properly to wear a mask to
you know be aware of
you know not being too close to people
we still did it
there were also new expressions of
frustration including a march to a local
rcmp detachment
but more answers won't come until a
public inquiry starts collecting
evidence
and no date has been set yet for the
start of those hearings
robin ross lord in truro nova scotia
thanks ross
coming up derek shovin's trial nears its
end
closing arguments will be made in the
derrick chauvin case tomorrow
and then it'll be up to a jury to
determine if the former minneapolis
police officer should be convicted of
murder or manslaughter
in the death of george floyd the trial
has delivered emotional witness
testimony along with expert opinions
about police tactics
and use of force jackson proskow reports
have you made a decision today whether
you intend to testify
or whether you intend to invoke your
fifth amendment privilege
uh i will invoke my fifth amendment
privilege today he declined to testify
in his own defense
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin will instead let the trial speak
for itself
that included dozens of emotional
witnesses i heard george floyd
saying i can't breathe please
get off of me i can't breathe who saw
george floyd take his last breaths in
the custody of chauvin and three other
officers
officer shobin seemed very comfortable
with
the majority of his weight balanced
on top of mr floyd's neck character
witnesses like floyd's girlfriend spoke
openly of his struggles with addiction
was there a time when you thought he
might be using again
yes
perhaps most devastating for the defense
chauvin's former boss the minneapolis
police chief
who testified that chauvin's actions
went against police training
that in no way shape or form is anything
that
is by policy expert after expert
testified a lack of
oxygen likely caused floyd's death
during the 9 minutes and 29 seconds he
was under chauvin's knee
along with the failure to provide any
first aid is there another name for
death by oxygen deficiency asphyxia
the defense called far fewer witnesses
their strategy
so doubt about the actual cause of death
it is frequently
said and trained to police officers that
a person can
talk it means they can breathe witnesses
brought up floyd's heart condition
drug use and added speculation about
carbon monoxide from the tailpipe of the
police car
you put all of those together it's very
difficult to say which of those is the
most
accurate so i would fall back to
undetermined
no weak in this particular case the jury
will consider
three potential charges second-degree
murder third degree murder or
second-degree manslaughter
any decision to convict will have to be
unanimous
no matter what happens to chauvin the
trial will not bring about the end of
the saga
the three other officers charged with
aiding and abetting will be tried
jointly in august
jackson prosko global news washington
still ahead russia's military might can
the u.s
halt the march toward ukraine
there's a new cold war between russia
and the united states
this week the white house laid out
sanctions against russia
the kremlin responded by saying it would
expel 10 american diplomats
now in an attempt at diplomacy joe biden
wants to meet vladimir putin for a
face-to-face summit
at the top of the agenda russia's
military buildup on its border with
ukraine
as redmond shannon reports there are
fears moscow is planning
another invasion the russian military
heading west the kremlin had said these
movements were
no one else's business but this week
russia's defense minister said troops
were temporarily deployed to its western
border
in response to this defender europe 21
a huge nato exercise currently taking
place in eastern europe
nato and ukraine are concerned russia is
on
more than the defensive russian buildup
is taking place
not only along the border of ukraine but
along the border of democratic world the
ukrainian government says russia has
assembled
40 000 troops in crimea which russia
annexed from ukraine in 2014
and another 40 000 near its eastern
border close to the donbass region which
is
partially controlled by russian-backed
separatists
most likely reading of this situation is
that it's a tactic
of intimidation both for ukraine
but also for the new u.s administration
a bargaining tool perhaps in a possible
u.s russia summit proposed on tuesday by
president joe biden
ukraine's president volodymyr zielinski
who recently visited the front line
has said he wants to join nato until
ukraine
does so putin may have no real deterrent
he knows that the initial
stages of an offensive which if he does
launch it
will not be met with overwhelming force
from the ukrainian side
a lot of people are saying that putin is
just waiting for the ground to dry
the people on that ground particularly
in donbass
could again be the real losers they are
just
being you know used as the territory to
stage
further you know uh effort to undermine
ukraine
more than 13 000 people have died in the
conflict since 2014
redmond shannon global news london
up next the deadly warning about a
popular fitness machine
many of you may have heard about peloton
it's a popular brand of fitness machines
and tonight there's a warning about the
company's treadmill
the u.s consumer product safety
commission says it has received
several reports of injuries and one
death linked to the product
jennifer johnson has the details and a
warning some of the video in this story
is disturbing
the consumer product safety commission
issued this disturbing video showing two
small children playing on the peloton
tread plus
the young boy is sucked under the
machine which weighs over 204 kilograms
luckily he manages to wiggle out an
escape but after 39 incidents
including one death the cpsc issued this
statement
in light of multiple reports of children
becoming entrapped
pinned and pulled under the rear roller
of the product cpsc urges consumers with
children at home
to stop using the product immediately
the agency is looking for cooperation
from the popular treadmill producer
to stop any further accidents we have
been in discussions with peloton about a
recall and a stop sale
they have not agreed to that at this
point but we hope that will change
in the meantime we want to be sure to
tell consumers about this
issue hell time come on let's get this
workout started peloton sales
skyrocketed over 170
in the fourth quarter of 2020 as the
pandemic forced
gyms to close the company said it was
troubled by the cpsc warning and called
it inaccurate and misleading
peloton also said there's no reason to
stop using the treadmill
as long as all the warnings and safety
instructions are followed
the model that we're talking about here
is the tread plus but it's been known as
the tread
since 2018 so if you have the tread
model
or the tread plus it's the same model
we're advising you
not to use that treadmill other consumer
groups are backing the cpsc's decision
stop using the peloton tread plus
if you have kids at home experts say
with the treadmill costing over four
thousand dollars peloton needs to fix
the problem
the cpsc says if the company doesn't
agree to a voluntary recall
the agency may have to take peloton to
court something that could take years to
resolve
jennifer johnson global news washington
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is laurentia beach
in manitoba
we would love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and be sure to tune
in to our special budget coverage good
night
[Music]
you